ready at the point that it was getting
to I I wasn't surprised that something
bad happened
this is a 23 billion dollar industry
they sent her home in a box if she was
that sick why didn't I know
after my face was paralyzed and I was
just like so confused like why are they
doing this to me
[Music]
in America's Mountain Wilderness
outposts of a multi-billion Dollar
business operate beyond the public clear
this complex is one of hundreds of
treatment centers Across America for
so-called troubled teens children with
all manner of issues from bad behavior
to video game addiction to severe
depression Ascent to what is essentially
a boarding school for the unruly some
stay for months or even years our goal
is to help these students become the
best versions of themselves desperate
parents struggling with difficult
children alerting by the promise that
their problems can be fixed with a mix
of therapy and tough love
but this is an industry plagued by
stories of neglect abuse and even death
I never thought I would have to bury my
child
I mean I wasn't even there for I didn't
I got told too late to even be there for
her
Dean's daughter Taylor loved animals and
trips to Disney World with her siblings
but she began to struggle with what her
father calls emotional issues she left
their home in Washington to attend
Diamond Ranch Academy a troubled teen
School in Utah
by last December after 15 months there
she was dead
the cause of death hasn't yet been
determined but Taylor's family believed
she had sepsis a blood infection which
is the body's extreme reaction to
infection her dad doesn't even know
where or why she died I never got
anything about her going to the doctor
if she was that sick
why didn't you know why didn't I know
and they should have told me something
I would imagine you never expect to send
your child to what's supposed to be a
reputable educational facility and not
get them back no they sent her home in a
box
I mean
I still think one of these days she's
just gonna walk in the door it's not
gonna happen
School medical records obtained by Sky
News suggests Taylor was vomiting
regularly in the days before she died
one staff note says Taylor was angry
because she felt like staff weren't
trying to help with her being sick
lately Dean do you think this whole
industry needs reform across the board
oh 100 they look at our children as
paychecks
the 12-ish plus thousand dollars a month
Taylor's just gonna be really missed
losing her devastated our family
our whole
Community I said Taylor was I mean
Taylor was loved
they told all the students this morning
listen to how staff were told of
Taylor's death this is a cover audio
recording of a director breaking the
news provided to me by a whistleblower
unfortunately like for me this isn't the
first time I've had to deal with this
probably won't be the last depending on
how long I stay here
because Taylor's death isn't an isolated
case
in Utah alone three children have died
in the past two years at residential
facilities schools more alleged physical
and emotional abuse
I'm on a journey from the capital Salt
Lake City into the rugged depths of this
state there are more than 100 troubled
teen schools in Utah most are privately
run and often charged between ten and
fifteen thousand dollars a month for
each child
some teenagers tell of being made to
hike for hours with bags filled with
rocks and being deprived of food and
sleep
for many their experience of this
industry begins in the pitch black with
a so-called authorized kidnapping
parents pay for their children to be
taken from home and transported to
facilities sometimes thousands of miles
away and even restrained with handcuffs
or cable ties
strangers go into teenagers bedrooms in
the middle of the night take them often
from their beds bundle them into the
back of Vans and drive them down dark
roads like this to these camps in the
middle of nowhere it really is hard to
believe that this is legal
they're completely cut off when they
show up in the middle of the night and
I've been there and the first thing they
asked where am I
the one kid asked where am I it's like
dude you're in Utah
Matt was a night watch attendant at
Diamond Ranch Academy where Taylor
Goodrich died he says he encountered
multiple instances of physical
confrontations at the campus
I felt like every day I was coming to
coming in and there was new holes in the
wall
body size hole here fist size hole there
head size hole there some of the kids do
it sometimes it's from the staff members
putting the kids into the wall how cut
off are these kids from the outside
world when they're in these schools
residential centers if they try to mail
a letter off to their parents it would
get sent back with corrections on it you
can't say this you can't say that and so
there even though letters were getting I
guess redacted basically so that certain
information wasn't leaving the school
what was Diamond Ranch like from your
experience what like in the way that
they cared for the children in their
custody
at the point that it was getting to I
wasn't surprised that something bad
happened
I just was getting a feeling I was
getting more and more uncomfortable on
even on the boys campus with
them not being taken care of I was
overworking myself I was working six
seven days a week because I honestly
didn't trust anybody else
with my group of kids
so this is you at Diamond Ranch yeah
Shea Renner was sent to Diamond Ranch
for several months in 2015 because of
behavioral problems speaking publicly
about her experiences there for the
first time she claims staff would
terrorize her on a weekly basis were you
surprised Shea when you heard what
happened to Taylor there
um
not at all
just that like
if more people knew like
like
if I knew like my rights
and did something sooner like everyone
else
Shay Renna alleged staff would
physically restrain her not was a
legitimate practice but as a form of
punishment
she suffered partial facial paralysis
after being held down on the ground
my feet were taken from underneath me
and I was dropped to the floor
and they started doing the
pressure points and I was dropped down
again for the second time in that time
instead of just doing the these pressure
points they went onto my face and
um after a while
they released me and I could feel like
my face there was something funny with
my face
these pictures show her face before and
after the incident
I felt really like
trapped yeah
I felt a lot a lot of things felt
hopeless and hopeless
um
I remember
like after my face was paralyzed sitting
in front of my counselor and I was just
like
so confused like why are they doing this
to me
hi there we're from Sky News UK
television nobody at Diamond Ranch would
speak officially about these allegations
but as we were filming Riley Diaz a
director there whose family owns the
facility emerges from the building a
children's safe coming here
can I ask can you answer that though
that's the most basic question isn't it
our children safe coming to Diamond
Ranch
yeah I've seen your videos but it's it's
conflicts with what we're being told
about what happens here we will
absolutely speak to anything and
everything okay we're very transparent
you're saying you're transparent but
what's not transparent is how Taylor
Goodrich died her dad says he doesn't
even know whether she died here or died
at the hospital or you know he doesn't
even know the answer for for a parent
who's in such profound pain to not know
whether his daughter died here died at
hospital
whether she was you know he thinks her
sickness was ignored by staff and I just
can't say anything you can't answer
those questions I can't say anything I
can't say anything
in a statement a spokesperson for
Diamond Ranch Academy says we're unable
to reply to specific allegations
relating to specific students due to the
operation of various federal and state
laws Diamond Ranch academies contesting
the allegations in the appropriate
venues and will present evidence in
court as opposed to the media
Taylor's death has prompted fresh calls
for major reform of this industry by
people who say that these residential
facilities are putting profit over child
welfare
leading the charge is Paris Hilton she
spent time in three troubled teen
facilities
for nearly a year aged 16 she was here
at Provo Canyon School in the foothills
of Utah's Wasatch mountains
Paris says she was verbally physically
and sexually abused well prep posters
together with Rebecca a manager at her
company they pushed for reform of the
troubled teen industry we are approached
every single day with survivors of this
industry who are coming out of these
particular programs and stating that
they too have been abused
Paris alleges she was woken in the
middle of the night and forced to
undergo sham gynological exams
well those who went to Provo claim they
were force-fed medication and held in
solitary confinement for 20 hours a day
in response to the allegations Provo
Canyons owners say the school was sold
in 2000 and they cannot comment on the
operations or student experience prior
to that time but they do say they don't
condone or promote any form of abuse
I don't feel you can look at this
industry without looking at the profit
motivations of it so we've calculated
that this is a 23 billion dollar
industry
and they're treating around 200 to 300
000 kids annually and so these
facilities are sent incentivized to keep
kids longer to bill for services
and obviously the list goes on and on
at Utah's state capital Senator Mike
McKelly's working on National laws to
protect children in troubled teen
schools he wants to regulate the secure
Transportation industry known for those
authorized kidnappings kids that are
picked up in the middle of the night by
two large men when you start treatment
with that level of trauma I think it's
extremely problematic if I'm King for
the day I ban it entirely I I just don't
think I think the amount of damage we're
doing versus the amount of good we're
we're creating and I think the damage
far outweighs the good I've got kids
what I send my kids to a to a facility
not a chance I would never I would never
do that based on what what I've seen
many of the troubled teen graduates I've
spoken to describe a system which has
done more to harm than help Taylor
goodridge's family will never know what
she might have done with her life
instead they're left with two boxes of
her belongings returned from Diamond
Ranch the graduation medal
and letters from her peers
it is little Comfort but they hope her
tragic death will result in the school
being shut down they want more
accountability too of an industry which
takes in the most vulnerable but has for
too long operated unchecked Martha
Kellner Sky News Utah
we've had a response to Martha's report
from Utah's Health and Human Services
Department you've given us this
statement residential programs are a
critical part of Utah's mental health
system and Continuum and the health and
safety of the vulnerable populations
they serve must be their highest
priority we want to make sure all Utah
license providers are in full compliance
with the rules to ensure the safety of
those they serve